let's see if this works what up guys
welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel
um I'm your host Pearl
all right guys I'm trying to
I got new extensions
and I don't really yeah we're working on
this anyways
um
so today
I decided that I always talk about on my
channel
if you're applying to a job
if you're applying to a job okay
actually let me let me make sure I'm
live I don't want to do a whole
monologue and then not be live you know
what I mean okay so
let me just double check
make sure this [__] is live
um
no
it's Purl a lot let's see
what the
this isn't supposed to be episode 105
how did I end up on here okay I need to
edit this stream let me
this is supposed to be a reaction stream
[Music]
um
okay wait
okay let me fix this
edit
can women why does it say the pregame
episode oh my gosh
duplicate
can women
okay I don't know why this is a pre-game
episode it's not supposed to be
okay let me switch it
um let's
what is your wife resume
okay and then
I would like to switch it to instead of
um I think it's this one
well I guess the reactions
thing doesn't really work either okay
anyways now we're back we're back sorry
guys I had to fix the stream so
today what's Pearl talking about one can
I get a compliment on the hair on the
hair thank you thank you okay so on the
show I constantly say
if you're applying to a job
you would have a resume and talk about
your work experience now
oftentimes in the in the manosphere in
the red pill
we we get mad at the women right they
have these high standards and they bring
nothing to the table
but let's
let's examine that okay that's true
that's absolutely true modern women we
bring very little
to the table however
I'm gonna play devil's advocate for two
seconds okay two seconds when I ask the
men
questions like
what should women bring to the table
their answers are very Broad
respect caring loving feminine like
let's let's take one of those feminine
what does that mean now it's tough right
because feminine it's kind of like you
just know it when you see it we can all
think of that girl that's naturally just
a fit a freaking feminine woman right in
our heads but you can't really describe
what it is now let's say we have a
masculine woman listening
how does she take that and give
and go from try now I do I really think
you can go from being 100 masculine to
100 100 feminine no no I don't I think
it's very unlikely however
if she wanted to make changes in the
right direction how would she do that
if you guys give these broad answers no
you may say pearl it's so simple you
guys should just know and peace right we
talk about peace but
when you guys say what you want it's
very broad like peace what does that
mean now it's hard because you kind of
know what it means when
you hear it like you can you can think
of somebody
or wife or someone that brings their
husband peace but if you were talking to
a non-peaceful woman how would you
instruct her to be more peaceful
okay
let the man take the lead look and you
guys have you guys have great again now
let's so what I decided was
I'm gonna share my screen
um
wish I could be bigger
blessings here but he's doing ant show
right now
it's just thinking okay
so
I really wish I could make this bigger
oh that won't work
okay well
I'm just like why is it like this I'm so
tiny whatever okay I'm gonna be in the
can I flip it could I flip it so I'm big
and this no okay
so
let's let's start with the resume
let's start so I'm like let's let's
construct a wife resume if you guys had
the perfect wife
what would be on her resume so let's
let's start she has to be good with kids
right so
and if a girl was gonna come to a guy
and say hey I'm ready to be a wife here
is my resume what should be on it now I
need specific job experience history
I'll give you an example okay let's
let's talk about
is there a better word for good with
kids okay
sorry better I'm gonna make the font
bigger is there a better word for this
can't make yourself larger there I can't
figure it out guys
oh my God am I bigger now
oh is blessing fixing it
thank you blessing thank you
I was like he's busy he's on stream now
okay
good with kids so what we could do is
an example of a
um this is still pretty small on the
screen let me make this bigger
an example of a work experience could be
babysit
cousins or brothers and sisters whatever
it is between the ages of zero to seven
twice a week
now if a man was looking for a girl
that's good with kids and she said hey
I'm good with kids I babysit my cousins
twice a week they're between the ages of
zero and seven and
I I watched those little Little Rascals
you know I do a good job whatever
okay
um
what else could we put on there so like
let's say cooking
now if you want to grow all that cooks
so you could put now I'm not saying that
this is my resume I'm just gonna
but everyone always harps on Me Pearl
you have no Solutions you just harp on
women
do most modern women want to babysit
their cousins between the ages of zero
and seven twice a week
in order to prepare to be a mother
don't shoot the messenger okay don't
shoot the messenger
okay
now I'm just I'm gonna add more I know
so because what
they always say
you know what should women bring to the
table fit feminine friendly okay and
that's great but it really doesn't get
into the specifics and the nitty-gritty
if I'm a girl that's never seen a wife
and I'm like hey I'm nice I'm friendly
hey I'm fit okay I'm I'm working out but
if I'm a girl from let's just say a not
so great area where I don't have
feminine women examples okay
fit feminine I'm not going to know what
feminine is and I'm also not gonna know
I'm gonna think friendly is the same
thing as being cooperative those are two
different things you can be friendly and
you can be friendly and still say I
ain't listening to [__] you say
right
I could say it in a friendly tone
I'm sorry I'm sorry guys okay
and I know to the men you're like well
what you guys have to do is so simple
we're not even asking for much you're
right I agree with you
but
let's let's pretend we're talking to a
five-year-old okay let's pretend we're
talking to someone that has never seen a
stable functioning relationship okay so
if you wanted to be a good cook you
could go to culinary you could send okay
I cook dinner every night
for myself and my roommate
um
like I'm just thinking if she's in her
20s you know I cook dinner every night
for myself and my roommate I
cook dinner every night for myself and
my roommate
um
meals specialty meals
meals include I'll do mine I'll do mine
jollof rice
and I know it I still gotta you know
French toast
[Music]
um
also if you hear snoring that's my dog
I'm sorry guys look at we're Balling on
a budget out here
um
July Fridays French toast
um chicken drumsticks
um
Indian food it's just we could the list
goes on right okay
you guys get the idea good with kids
cooking I cooked so so if a girl came to
you on a date and you're like look it
and also guys a lot of you we have to
think about what type of wife
do you guys want do you want to be
paying 100 of the bills or as a girl do
you want him to pay a hundred percent of
the bills
okay I mean we could want what we want
are you gonna get a guy
are you gonna are you gonna get a guy
that's gonna pay a hundred percent of
the bills so and What would life
like that look like like you know if
you're with a guy that's paying a
hundred percent of the bills he might
want you to need need some bread from
scratch you got the time you're home all
day why can't my man get some bread from
scratch
but if you're working 20 30 hours a week
are you really gonna have time to need
the bro you know I'm just I'm just
Pearl's just thinking here
so
cooking
so let's say I cook dinner every night
for myself and my roommate you could
even my brothers my brother's fiance
this is how she got the Ring went to
culinary school for fun
um I don't I don't know what the
official certification she has I'll just
say did culinary school so you could
come to a guy and you could say hey hey
I I want to be your wife okay here's
here's my resume I'm good with kids I
babysit my so when a guy says what do
you bring to the table you could say I'm
good with kids I babysit my cousins
between the ages of zero and seven twice
a week
um I know how to and the more in
specific we talk the more I know that
it's real okay I know how to
I know you could put like
and you could even put you know
I think you can volunteer to like
watch babies I think you know I'm just
I mean we'll just stick to babysitting
we'll just stick to babysitting okay you
could say cooking like let's just say
you're in your 20s right
I cook dinner for myself and my roommate
every night my specialty meals include
jollof rice fries french toast chicken
drumsticks Indian food
um
whatever it is okay and I went to
culinary school for three months um
because I just wanted to learn
that is something that you bring to the
table
table now
what other skills could a more Modern
Man want
because let's be honest
is there men that want more modern
skills from women
now
I'm just thinking of my good friend
Donovan's relationship okay his
girlfriend now fiancee
and also stop stop talking trash about
Donovan y'all Donovan's my boy Donovan's
I don't really want to make this stream
about Donovan That's my boy
um
you know there's there's more to certain
situations than meets the eye but when
you're in the middle of a legal battle
there's only so much you can you
yourself can say
um but that I'm just gonna leave that at
that but I think of his situation
his
fiance does his proficient
in SEO now are most men gonna want this
do most men need SEO and marketing
no I'm just
trying to put in everything that a girl
could potentially bring to the table
okay
look it
um proficient and SEO marketing
worked at a marketing firm
for
kit
two years
um and I don't know you can put in some
stats about
SEO search stat I don't do SEO
someone else might look I'm gonna put
seos maybe I should all right now what
else
um
let's see what else can we put
oh
in shape
um you could put hypothetically
I do a call-in show what does your wife
resume look like
send me your wife resumes people just
pearlythings.gmail.com okay in shape um
go to the gym and go to the gym three
times a week so if I was to put the
In-Shape thing I would put
Semi-Pro athlete
goes to the gym
I would say three times a week and has
done that week and has done so
for
like seven years
I I really have not gone a long time
without going to the gym
um
[Music]
I'm trying to see what else is in here
um
to put in shape right now next next
also I have a coffee not not a coffee a
quick coffee a chai tea all right being
delivered so
you know blessing if you're watching
this turn off turn off the buzzer just
just just in case that they buzz you
know I know there's a live going on
right now
um
oh someone's putting financial literacy
literacy financial literacy now as a
woman you should probably look at these
and I'm gonna put cleaning on here too I
know I know guys and we probably want to
think what are we naturally good at
and because personally and this is just
something my dad always told me he
always told me to do what you love and
do what you're naturally good at and
spend more time doing the things you're
good at rather than trying to get good
at the things you're bad at so like
personally accounting financial literacy
a lot of money I'm very cheap
but I just don't have I'm very creative
I don't have the skill set to be an
accountant and I could spend all this
time trying to be an accountant
is never going to be me but let me just
put this if we're gonna have the perfect
you know wife financial literacy
um
Pearl you need to break down the purpose
of a resume first then frame the type of
job a woman would apply for to get a
good man
look it
I'm breaking down the resume but the
whatever okay so financial literacy so
so we want to say
can balance so I'm gonna be making [__]
up because I I have a very hard time oh
[__]
with accounting geez
you can balance a budget
um
[Music]
can balance a budget I don't know does
accounting stuff
see this is the part I'm like look at
this is
oh no debt
no debt that's a good one
some of the intangibles now guys
remember I know you're thinking this is
so simple Pearl
why don't women just know this
because we're idiots we are idiots we
are not we don't read between the lines
um and we're honestly we're lazy a lot
of us are lazy we don't want to put in
the work and I'm not saying most women
will but I'm just saying what should
women bring to the table so the top
comment was respect
How could a woman make a resume that
shows that she is respectful
what skills jobs or positions
should she have put herself in to prove
that she is respectful let me see in the
comments
um
someone coming in
oh I'm sorry
55.
hold on guys
[Music]
um
oh that's a good one not talking
negatively about a previous employer
that's a good one
foreign
yes I know you're live and I'm bringing
it yes yes I'm sorry Auntie I'm sorry I
just it was yeah it was it was good it
was good
she told me I need to stop ordering chai
tea what the hell
the
oh my gosh
I was wondering why this was so
expensive
cup
listening who keeps farting oh my gosh
my it's my dog guys it's my dog okay
um okay guys let me know in the chat
helping her family
team player but guys again again so if I
was going to a job interview and they
said prove to me that you are respectful
trying to think how would I answer that
question I would say well you know I've
worked for I've had I would probably use
my athletic experience I've had you know
eight different coaches you know
um
how many faucets have I had
I do talk [__] about my last job I
really hated that job though I no other
job but just my last one oh my gosh oh
my gosh I would say you know I had five
different bosses um I had really good
relationships with all of them
and I always had good things to say
about me
you know what else what else cordial and
polite to the elderly
um
does not talk behind people's backs okay
there you go does
behind okay
so then all right let's go to freaking
let's go and guys this can be edited and
changed you know this is just a rough we
can go through it at the end
should I go get a cup
hey blessing can you bring me a cup
Auntie blessing if you're watching I
didn't realize they were gonna bring me
this like big bag I thought this was
gonna be a cup of chai
you know just if you could give me like
the big cup from from the kitchen
they're gonna bring it I think anyways
okay
um what
what else respect caring
loving and you know what I want to do
feminine first because that
I these femininity coaches confuse the
hell out of me oh my God they confused
the hell out of me because they say
these things that just mean nothing
they're like be feminine wear some
dresses I'm like so I can put a dude in
a dress and he's feminine now
all right let's do feminine energy
having qualities
um then our appearance traditionally
associated with women or girls
um what is it meant by being feminine
having qualities gentleness weakness
delicacy or modesty okay so oh
I got it so if we wanted to go
look at that wow I forgot my copy button
doesn't work in the UK
because this is a US keyboard
um okay
feminine what's up
it's gonna make me type whatever
um okay
what is a feminine example
okay gentle now let's do gentleness
gentleness
uh uh weakness delicacy
see it's like it's like the broad I'm
just a specific I need step-by-step
instructions type of gal
I'm starting to think they're not
bringing me the cup
um
nurturing
okay nurturing
um
they say Feminine is like cooking
cleaning and watching the kids
I disagree because a dude can cook clean
and watch the kids does that make him
feminine
no no
it's like I can get a masculine ass
to watch the kids cooking clean
who's that snoring my dog okay
I'm sorry
submissive Okay so
what could someone put on a resume
submissive
that shows that they are
this could be previous relationships
um
mm-hmm
caring gentleness
oh modesty we could do no revealing
pictures on Instagram
[Music]
no social media
um
okay guys I'm gonna go get a cup because
I don't think they're gonna bring it
one second I know I'm sorry one sec
huh
wow
curl prove to them that you're not a
lazy woman get the cup
well guys
you cease to Humble me every day
okay
what the hell
what the
I feel like this is gonna end poorly
okay
I just
it's very hot
okay I'm
okay maybe I'll let it cool down for a
second
I'm a little nervous on that one
okay
um weakness feminine
okay what else guys cook good with kids
cooking
when I Google is there such thing as a
resume
or a wife
[Music]
I zoom in this is so blurry
housewife stay-at-home mom resume
oh
do I have cleaning on here that I have
cleaning on here
no I didn't cleaning
cleaning would be
maybe housekeeper experience
um
I really want this chai tea okay guys if
I spill on live I'm gonna be mad at
myself
ah I got it I got it
okay
I just I thought this was coming in a
cup
wow I was wondering why it was so
expensive it was like 10 pounds
but I was like maybe it's far
foreign
yeah okay this is the beginning of this
let me let me see what else the comments
say humble oh humility that is a good
one oh my God
humility
accountability
but again this is the problem with a lot
of these descriptions for women they are
so Broad and you can't say okay this was
an example
of
oh you could give example
of time you took accountability
here we go maybe more than one all right
wife resume make your own chai tea from
scratch
oh this is fire
all right
[Music]
um
I like the description the Bible gives
of a wife okay what is that description
loyal Mary capable and strong the
perfect helper for her man for more than
one man
um for more than one man his wife is the
best thing he has got this is why they
say is this in the Bible
this is why they say the church panders
to women his wife is the best thing he
has going for him you're telling me if
Elon Musk had a wife that would be the
best thing he had going for him
Maybe
maybe I'm crazy I don't know
trustworthy faithful
okay we'll do trustworthy
and we can also flip these and help guys
get questions I would interview for a
good good wife
I mean granted women can talk faithful
and reliable
um okay
empathy I gotta work on that one
the other day I was talking about how I
don't feel bad for the crackheads that
live down the street for me
it's like maybe I need to be more
empathetic
just like if you chose to do crack
why it
like we all gotta do look it I have such
I have such strong opinions on
crackheads
hmm
oh
and men oh this is so true
my brothers say that
they really don't like high maintenance
girls now maybe I'm biased because your
girl your girl is very low maintenance
okay we don't don't need I I can live I
could wear no makeup for a month and I
would honestly be fine I don't
I don't think I have makeup on now no
honestly I I wouldn't even care I'm
I got these hair extensions that's big
for me
proverbs 31 okay
proverbs 31.
oh my gosh wait
the saying of King lemon and Oracle his
mother taught him
oh my son oh son oh son of my vows do
not spend your strength on women your
Vigor on those who ruin Kings it is not
for Kings oh lemon not for Kings to
drink wine not for rulers to Crave beer
lest they drink and forget what the law
decrees and deprive all the oppressed of
their rights
what does this talk about okay okay give
beer to those who are perishing wine to
those who are in anguish let them drink
and forget their proper poverty and
remember their misery no more
speak up for those who can't speak up
for themselves for the rights of those
who are destitute speak up and judge
fairly defend the rights of the poor and
the needy a wife of noble character who
can find she is worth more than rubies
her husband has full confidence in her
and lacks nothing of value
she brings him good not harm all the
days of her life she selects the wool
and flax and works with eager hands
ladies can you select wool and flax I
don't think so she has like Merchant
ships bringing her food from afar
she gets up while it is still dark she
provides food for her for her family and
portions for her servant girls
see even even the man had a rotation
we know what those servant girls were
doing we know we know
a field and buys it out of her earnings
and plants a Vineyard she sets about her
work vigorously her arms are strong for
her tasks she sees that her training is
profitable and her lamp does not go out
at night in
see
in her hands she holds the distaff and
grasps the spindle with her finger she
opens her arms to the poor and extends
her hands to the needy when it shows she
has no fear for her household for all of
them are clothed in Scarlet she makes
coverings for her bed she is clothed in
fine linen and purple her husband
respected at The City Gate where he
takes his seat among the Elders of the
land she makes Lin can you make linen
garments and sells them
see the Bible had boss babes okay she
makes linen garments and sells them and
supplies the merchant with this oh [__]
what should I do with this okay wait and
supplies the merchant with the sashes
uh where was I
okay she is clothed with strength and
dignity she can laugh at the days to
come she speaks wisdom and faithful
instruction on her tongue She watches
over the Affairs of her household and
does not eat the bread of idleness her
children arise call her blast her
husband also he Praises her many does
your husband praise you
would your husband say that you're
submissive
and honestly not not when you're there
and you ask him in front of your friends
in front of his boys would he say my
girl
many women do noble things but you
surpass them all charm is deception and
beauty is fleeting but a woman who fears
the Lord is to be praised
give her the rewards she has earned and
let her Works bring praise to her City
Gate okay
let's add sewing
I really don't like
could I bring
how do I zoom in on the screen I don't
actually know
because I wanna I kind of want to make
this a smaller font but I don't want it
to be bigger for you
you know I'ma just leave it I'm gonna
just leave it okay
um should I be on this side would I
better fit
oh what the hell no why can't I switch
my box
oh I just I I messed it up I'm sorry
blessing I'm sorry blessings working now
um
so
I what I realized was Kevin Samuels when
he would say are you a traditional woman
a lot of girls would say yes but they
wouldn't have this these skills and
these ex this experience
and he wasn't saying that well he did
say to buy a dog and die alone but he
was saying that because they wanted
traditional
outcomes without being
traditional women now
modern women
oftentimes can get moderate outcomes I
mean one of the biggest couples that I
see now is older women younger men
that's a modern outcome
women that make more than their men
that's a modern outcome if you're if
you're okay with that outcome
if you're okay with that outcome
that's fine but the issue becomes when
let's go back to my when you're
foreign
you have no traditional skills
skills you are not coachable
or
you have never seen a marriage
and you say make me a housewife
now the men are gonna look at you like
your nuts because
these are what the traditional women and
often women that are overseas bring to
the table were you you
know how to post on tick tock
know how to
order takeout okay now
there's nothing wrong with a modern
outcome if you want to both work
if you want a bowl
go 50 50 on the bills
that's fine but don't why would you
expect to be corded traditionally
why would you expect for a traditional
outcome if you're not a traditional
woman you don't have the skills for it
now and the problem is now some girls
can find a guy that will Coach them
into this but what evidence do you have
that you are coachable
have your previous bosses liked you what
would your ex-boyfriend say
so that's why the men are saying
you guys are nuts when you say make me a
housewife
make me a housewife but
I have no housewife skills
and another thing and I was really
thinking about this guys
I was really thinking about this oh my
gosh am I not on the screen
what the hell has my audio been off
okay let me and I've been thinking about
this
so you could go the modern way all the
way okay let's just say you want to be a
power couple 50 50. maybe the girl makes
a little bit more you know
um
okay so I'm just gonna I'm sorry
I need to I need to fix this all right
let's let's say we do this all right
the issue we're gonna have what kind of
Life do you guys see yourself having
okay
what what type of life so
Thanksgiving Christmas
are you good with ordering takeout for
that or hiring people
now most people can't afford to hire
people but let's just live in la la land
for two seconds right
do you want a quality of life where you
have random people in your house all the
time
now
my dad does a lot
even though he has money to hire things
out
there's something my dad told me where
he just said it's nice to just know how
to do things yourself
and I didn't really understand it
because I was like Dad your time is
worth thousands of dollars an hour like
we live in 2023 why are you still doing
the plumbing yourself why are you still
doing the electricity yourself or and a
lot of people would argue he's wasting
his time
and you could argue that but the thing
is
it's empowering to have skills
that will take you through life in every
situation so if the plumbing goes out he
doesn't have to call a plumber wait for
the plumber to get there he can just fix
it himself and
it takes them like maybe an hour to fix
it where he'd have to wait for the
plumber and then you have to depend on
the plumber and then you just let in a
random plumber into your house where
things could have like and
I'm not necessarily saying one's wrong
or the other because people that
Outsource everything and allows them to
get really good at certain skills but
what I am saying is a lot of people
don't think about that it takes away
from your quality of life there is
something different about a mother
cooking dinner in the kitchen than it is
taking your family out to dinner at a
restaurant
it is just different and I can't really
tell you why I can't really explain it
you're with the same people but there's
something about like learning things
together as a family like when I was a
kid we would
and I want to say I'm not saying that my
upbringing was 100 traditional it
certainly was not I was an athlete I
missed dinners at night a lot of the
time okay I really cared about
volleyball and it wasn't necessarily A
Bad Thing
just a more modern way we're a more
traditional way would be having dinner
together as a family every night no
matter what and as I've said in the past
everything comes at a cost and
but one way that my parents would try to
make up for the fact that
all the kids were in travel Sports
um my dad would travel for work my mom
would try out like there was just a lot
is that my mom and dad would take a
whole month off in the summer to make us
go
um and I say make because at the time I
was not that ecstatic about it travel
the U.S and
I'm I really hated it because it wasn't
like you guys have these luxury
vacations okay and you would think we
were that we made luxury money why
weren't we on luxury vacations we never
draw we never flew anywhere we had a 16
passenger van all I grew up with six
kids in the house
all six of us would get into that [__]
and it would be crowded everyone have
all their [__] and we would drive we
drove from Chicago to Oregon do you know
how far of a drive that is you want to
kill each other and someone was always
crying someone was always fighting like
you want to kill each other by the time
you get there
bickering whatever but what we found was
by the end of the trip
you just felt so much closer to your
family and while we could have went to a
resort where everyone does everything
for you you don't lay a finger there is
something about going through struggle
as a family together and like coming out
on top so
it just brings everyone closer and you
just spend more time together than if
everyone's on their phones in their
rooms being waited on
and that's why I think a lot of times
even when people have money they feel
more lonely because they're really not
spending like that quality time with
their immediate family
um
and there's a lady that I grew up by and
I could never they were so wealthy like
they were richer than us you know they
had like family money they had
like they're probably worth more than 50
million okay and the
they lived in like a two three bedroom
house maybe it was two two boys so two
bedroom house
um a farm
and
and freaking
I we always thought it was crazy that
this woman made all of her meals from
like scratch scratch
she like I have never seen a busier
housewife in my life oh my gosh
she would instead of getting like
groceries delivered she would drive to
the grocery store and like make sure she
looked at all the meats to make sure it
was like fresh and and it was just it
was impressive my lord and there was
just something about that Family like
they just were really close
um
and there was something about I don't
know I guess the love that goes into
like someone that's really like doing
all these things for you because she was
really serving her husband I'm gonna
have her on the channel one of these
days
oh someone sent me a wifey resume
let's see
sorry I'm I get off topic so the real
question is
what
do you want your life
to look like and this is what Kevin
Samuels would ask at 50. do you want to
do you want to cook
do you want to cook three meals a day
or your family
oh you know what you could do you could
put nutritionist under
the in shape like nutritionist
that would be a plus
um
so the real question is do you want to
cook three meals oh how do you want to
interact
with your husband
how much say
do you want in decisions because if you
go for okay guys if you go for
a guy that's say 20 years older than you
makes
a ton of money
how much say do you really expect to
have in decisions
a younger guy you're probably going to
have a little more say an influence than
a guy that's a lot older than you've
been doing the same thing
not a bad thing not a bad thing okay
how much say okay do you want to cook
all how much say
um
homeschool
or
homeschool private or public school now
again not all of you will have these
these options okay
some of you
will you don't make enough money public
school it is public school
um
what are some other good questions what
do you want your life to look like at 50
put them in the chat
sometimes you guys have better ideas
than I do
the sound of pearl gulpit I'm sorry okay
I'm sorry I'm sorry okay
[Music]
um
rich people don't give their secrets I
disagree with you rich people absolutely
give away their secrets oh oh stop it
okay I am
look at you guys can hate on me all you
want but I'm good at YouTube I know a
lot about YouTube I know a lot about
putting a team together
I know a lot and honestly I have given
so much free advice to people that want
to learn half y'all won't do it I could
give you a step-by-step guide
how
to get rich at YouTube you have most of
you all wouldn't even do it okay
um oh can a man say that's final to you
oh good question we're gonna we're gonna
keep making this
we're gonna keep Doug that was it can a
man say
that is final to you
rich people give advice they just don't
give their connections
um that's really not true either as long
as I might not give a connection if I
pay them and I don't want the price to
go up
I might avoid that but overall no
oh sorry that's that's a no-brainer how
many kids do you want
and what type of Lifestyle
lifestyle should those those kids have
how
um
family trips
oh where do you want to live
because this is something that a lot of
times we don't think about
like
it's kind of been a bit of a problem for
me dating in England right I don't want
to stay here your girl wants to get out
I I wish I was I wish I was in America
right now but it's not as simple as just
upping and leaving when you've built a
whole studio and a whole
business here so I'm doing it as fast as
I can but I'm not God right would I
really be happy
marrying someone
in England
I really would not I really wouldn't
because I I need to be a flight away
from my family I just and in the long
term even if it was a really great guy
that I could love if I'm not a flight
away from my family I just don't think
I'd be happy so
um
what other questions
oh great question what percentage of the
bills let me go back
of the bills
do you want to be responsible for
so this is why this question was so
delusional to Kevin because a lot of
times the girls would say oh 20 30 of
the bills okay if that's true
do you have some of these skills good
with kids how often do you babysit how
often do you cook
now again they're people that have
modern relationships all the time they
figure out how to make it work I'm not
even trying to [__] on them but a lot of
times as women we want traditional
outcomes but we don't have
traditional
skills and then you'll have these stupid
influencers on Tick Tock these women and
half of these girls it's like their
first relationship they got some sucker
let's just be honest some they got they
got some sucker okay
who doesn't really understand women he
doesn't even understand like what he can
get and maybe she did get the ring okay
this is just my opinion maybe she got
the ring okay maybe
she did get that traditional outcome
but it's only because she's hotter than
most girls and she got away with it
but they give this advice to all these
girls oh just raise your standards but
don't bring
any of
up here this to the table they don't
they don't ever talk about that okay
how did I end up in England
okay what uh what is the role of a wife
that's a great question Doug what is the
role of the wife
what does
a partnership mean to you
oh these are great questions wow
what was I saying
um
oh and they'll just lie to these girls
oh you can get anything just raise your
standards [__]
yeah
try that if you're overweight what I
want to see is a traditional you know
what you know what I'll believe a
traditional girl
or a girl that's maybe not that
attractive that got that outcome
okay
[Music]
oh oh another good question
how much money
does it take
to fund your lifestyle
oh my God that's such a good question
because I'll see these girls okay
that come in and they have now
it's a bit different I do well on
YouTube and I don't even have my nails
done I should I really should I'm in
entertainment there's no reason I
shouldn't but average cost
of nails
of nail salon per month so let's see
um
okay usually costs 25
Okay so
so about a hundred bucks and let's give
it 75. so 150 bucks a month
let's just say nails
see I don't even know because I'm so
freaking low maintenance now let's say
average cost of
I don't know
hair dye what do you want to do hair dye
so let's say she dyes her hair
um
she goes to a salon let's say
nails and I'll just say I think it's
more than that but let's just say 150
for hair
um
[Music]
what else oh let's do eyelash extensions
cost now I want you guys to know my
brothers okay they're down to earth guys
loyal
um 120 a month let's just say for
for eyelash extensions and when you guys
have when you ladies have all this [__]
okay and I'm not saying it doesn't make
you look better it certainly does but
when you have your nails done your hair
done that your eyelash extensions a face
full of makeup the latest and greatest
clothes my brothers
men I I know okay which are generally in
a higher socioeconomic status okay
then most people know okay they look at
that as a headache they look at that as
wasting money okay this is how my
brother would see this 150 for a nail
and let's be honest there's probably
more with clothes and all that [__] hair
nails is 150 a month so 300 so let's
just say
450 bucks a month for for maintaining
this girl
um even if it's even if they split the
bills or whatever right
450 times
12. that's five grand a year so my
brother's gonna calculate this out is
this girl really worth 20 grand over
four years
and you might be if you have some of
let's go back to the chart
some of these skills
but often times you want to be
maintained
but you have none of the skills that
make you worth maintaining
now guys I'm not saying this in a place
of pearls better than you I certainly
have many skills that I need to learn as
well and there's many ways that I too
have learned about things that I need to
improve on
but
this
this is where the delusion comes in and
now you'll say well what percent of men
can actually pay the bills and this is
something that is unfair
there is always one thing that men can
provide you with
protection and I know it's that you're
like oh well biology we can't help that
they just naturally
guys
I get really scared sometimes at night I
will freak myself out okay
and
the one thing that is really nice when
I'm home
is I have my brother and I have my dad
and I feel so protected by my brother
and my dad I know they would not let
[__] happen to me
anything happen they're gonna go get
their gun and shoot whoever's head off
right and
unfortunately that is something
automatically maybe women don't value it
maybe you can buy a gun
but at the end of the day we're weaker
than men and they're quicker than us
they could just take the gun from us I I
know we can shoot them right in the U.S
anywhere not the UK but at the end of
the day like female police officers get
overpowered to get their guns taken all
the time
that happens all the time like men get
their guns taken so there is something
that men automatically bring to the
table even if you're dating a guy that
doesn't make a lot of money splits 50 50
with you that's something they
automatically can bring to the table and
even the most
basic or like maybe not traditional men
will bring that to the table and it's
it's unfortunate I don't even say
unfortunate it's good for us we should
be thankful for it but when it comes to
The Exchange
that's just automatically something they
got
and in all honesty if you're dating him
he interested in him in any way he
probably brings more than you think to
the table
okay let's be out because you're not
going to be interested in him
unless he's got a certain
engagement questionnaire this should
help
um oh
top 50 questions to ask before you get
engaged
oh these are great questions
um
okay let me go back to the chat is the
dog snoring yes the dog is snoring I'm
sorry okay
um she's a 10 but she gets take out
oh now I have to sneeze
oh my gosh sorry guys
women need Hobbies okay guys let me know
in the chat is women's Hobbies important
to you now I feel like women's hobbies
are important but not for the reason you
guys think
I am a [__] with Hobbies okay I can
play guitar I dabble with I play piano a
bit
I sing I played semi-pro basketball
Semi-Pro volleyball
um
I freaking
YouTube
[Laughter]
I am a girl I love learning I love
Hobbies I I read economics books
sometimes not as much these days I I got
busier but men
don't seem to care that much however
they do like you to have hobbies because
they don't want you [__] around in
these streets like if you're not doing
Hobbies what are you doing
what are you doing
as long as your hobby isn't clubbing or
drinking
um
what else okay so how much does it take
to fund your lifestyle
oh could you go down and let this was a
great question Kevin used to ask
and then I'm so tired of you guys saying
oh she steals she steals Kevin Samuels
talking points
um you know what you know what's funny
you guys accuse me of stealing
everyone's stuff and it's just like if
you're gonna accuse me of stealing
someone's stuff could you pick one
because it's like I credit everybody
that I got inspiration from really I
really do
it's like
oh my gosh Kevin Samuels I looked up to
him so much that is the one person I
wish I could have collabed with
like I was oh my gosh you know what's
funny I talked to him before he died in
December and he told me he was coming to
London in March and I remember thinking
if I can get this show big enough maybe
maybe you're April he said spring and I
was like maybe I can get him to come on
the show
a shame a shame
um
oh how religious are you oh that's a
great question
how religious are you
and what
would family
would religion
and how would oh let's do and how would
play out
in the family
[Music]
um
here's like 300 to 500 to cut and die
guys this is why I don't do that [__] oh
my God
300 oh my God for your hair now look it
I did just buy these extensions but I'm
sorry I'm sorry this I look at these
extensions as an investment
I'm on the YouTube
I'm trying to get some thumbnail pics
long term they probably won't stand
let's just
see Pearl's got to figure out how to
take care of this [__]
five let's say you do 500 a month times
12. six grand a year
times four years twenty four thousand
dollars now why is this a red flag I
deserve it I deserve to spend money on
myself I want to look good for my
husband
this is a red flag because you're
putting your personal that's money that
you can put towards a college fund
that's money you could put towards your
children and you want to spend it on you
instead of your children that is what
what what ladies and gentlemen selfish
and that's the problem with modern women
you can absolutely build a modern family
we're in modern times guys
I'm not saying
I would argue the traditional
family works better but we are in modern
times there's a lot of people going 50
50.
but if you believe that you're more
important than your family
and also I want to learn something I
want to talk about a pattern that I've
seen on my live streams
women
pretending like they don't understand
the question like I'll be like modern
women and they're like well what's a
modern woman you know damn well what a
modern woman is
you know damn well you're just trying to
have me explain it
so you can argue with it well are you a
modern woman Pearl okay let's say I am
is what I'm saying about modern women
true or false Pearl are you this is what
they'll do Pearl Pearl Pearl
are you married
you know maybe
if I learn this stuff five years ago I
would be but is what I'm saying true or
false
oh my God
and that's what they do okay when people
don't have a good argument and you'll
see these with like same with the
the anti-red pill guys
like the reaction channels that'll just
criticize it
they'll often make fun of the red
pillars and say oh well you're not Alpha
oh what kind of guys do you get but
that's personal insults and we're here
to talk about ideas not personal insults
and ask the woman how would you be able
to
oh that's a good one how
these are great questions
how
would you be able to cope at a high-end
business dinner and should and could a
man take you
able to cope
I mean could a man take you
etiquette table manners
I need I need Improvement here I'm kind
of a Messy eater
oh my gosh
um
and that's the other thing
and then they'll be like oh oh well
well Pearl Pearl you have a podcast
doesn't that make you a modern woman
okay sure is what I'm saying true or
false that's what we should stick to
okay true or false and then you guys
want like updates
up
play-by-plays
on my personal dating life guys I don't
need to give you guys play-by-plays okay
now
anyways
finishing school
see that would be oh manners that would
be let's go up here
manners
let's talk about finishing school that
could be one
up to the
oh shoot sorry guys I forgot this is not
um
and
and another question do you even want to
go to high-end business
dinners now guys I've been to private
banking events now I don't know what you
guys know about private banking but in
the US we're in the UK you have to have
a certain amount of money to be in
private banking my parents are in it so
I've been to these events now my parents
come from a middle class household so
even though maybe we grew up in the one
percent in terms of income I still grew
up in like
a middle class values I would say so I
go to some of these fancy events I don't
really feel like I fit in
I'm like these are people that have been
living on the silver spoon for 20 30
years I I get excited they rented out
the field museum at one of these events
and I was just so excited to be there I
was like oh my God this is so cool
I was not a classy lady
now
do you even want to go to these events
do you want to go if you were a group in
a certain lifestyle
do you want to change
do you want to go to one of these events
where you just don't feel like you fit
in I mean it's cool once a year but like
you want to go twice a month three times
a month but you know anyways
oh how well
how well
how well do you communicate in
relationships that's a good
do women know how to show gratitude to
the man in their relationship oh good
question
do women no
Pearl needs an etiquette coach I really
do if you guys know any I want to do an
episode of wife school on etiquette
Auntie says I gotta stop swearing so
much
my mom's coming next week I'll probably
bring her on a stream y'all
okay someone sent me a wife resume I'm
gonna look at it
engagement questionnaire
okay
all right let's let's guys you wanna you
wanna rate
I want to put this in a Google doc
because I don't
I don't need all y'all know in this
girl's information
so let's see
also guys what what social class did you
grow up in
because another thing we don't talk
about it is very hard to date across
social classes
so a lot of y'all y'all want these like
top one percent dudes can you really
speak like are are you really gonna be
happy
my dad my mom once said something to me
she always told me it is much harder to
date across social classes than it is
against anything
and she would say you can go like if
you're if you're okay I was raised I was
upper class right but I was raised like
more of a middle class person in terms
of our values and like who we grew up
around so I grew up more like upper
middle class and it's really hard to go
like if I dated
someone let's say there's upper class
I could maybe date at the uh
class wise up one but up two or down two
would be tough
so a lot of times you get these girls
that think like they'll talk about oh I
want to date a man that makes this much
money does this and it's just like have
you ever been in a room with these men
do you know how to talk to them because
if you really haven't grown up around
these guys it's gonna really hard to
feel be it's going to be really
difficult to feel like you fit in in
these rooms people are Cutthroat okay
um
paste this why is this not copying hold
on okay I'm gonna share the screen
okay so you know men
present why is this not working
okay well I think I can just
no one can see this right okay
fine I'll just share the screen I think
it's okay
um okay here's my resume feminine I have
a soft and a kind voice modest no social
media besides LinkedIn gentle caretaker
by Nature understanding and a good
listener I'm good with kids Nanny
professional for nearly a decade I
watched my younger sibling and cousins
before I turned 14 genuine interest in
knowledge and Child Development hyper
focus on ages zero to three see this is
if if you handed a man oh [__]
if you hand in a man this resume this
looks good cooking I worked for a
professional chef and learned many
skills from her I value home-cooked
meals and I love making them I have my
own recipes for nutritional wholesome
meals for babies children and adults
now guys so this is when a girl says
what do you bring to the table this
real answers respect I speak kindly to
everyone in every scenario I do not
attract attract drama because I don't
make space for it in my life I listen
before I speak accountability when my ex
broke up with me I reflected and
apologized to him for my poor behaviors
when I made a mistake at work I called
myself out and told my bosses how I will
do better and better and show them
Hobbies I sing it runs in my family I
took vocal classes when I was younger I
exercised and do yoga daily guys and let
me know what you would want to add to
this resume and let me know what if
there's any any red flags
um hiking and time Outdoors painting
goals I want to find a high value man to
build with commit to and marry I want to
be a mother and at least two biological
children and Foster and adopt as many as
possible I want to manage our households
full time when my kids are young while
my husband provides for us I want to
write and illustrate children's books I
want to help modern parents understand
their how their children's mind works
okay let's see
what are the red flags let's get some
feedback y'all what are the red flags on
this resume what would add what would
you want to add to it
um
humility okay let me put that in the
other one
[Music]
um
sounds too good to be true like she's a
con artist
that's pretty good
no male friends okay let's add that to
the
and this is just a brainstorming session
guys you know we're This is Gonna Change
oh no drinking is a good added they said
oh I can tell you guys how I quit
drinking
um
I don't want to say
hold on okay
Foster and adopt as many as possible
they said that's a red flag they're like
we are not trying to raise other men's
children we are not trying to do that
um writer equals creatives creatives are
a red flag damn it I'm a creative
um
okay put your body count on your resume
can you put the resume back up Pearl
yeah I can okay
um okay sorry I really don't know how to
zoom in on these cam um on here
genuinely I wish I knew how to how to
zoom in
well
um
um sharing the resume history what no
drinking
wouldn't mention an X and accountability
yeah they don't want to hear about your
ex
um
let's see women need to control drinking
sounds too professional
the
Control Alt is that okay that's what
they say control
let me try this control plus plus did
not work
I don't know it might be the UK try
Control Plus oh Control Plus in the
mouse wheel okay
with the control control Plus
oh [__] oh my God I'm sorry I think I
just I think I just put your email I'm
sorry I'm sorry oh my God I'm sorry
um
that I'm clicking the plus it's just not
working
um
go to the three dots on the upper right
well
pinch to zoom
um
Baxter unvaxed
no actually I have
I don't hear her I don't hear her
personality traits her core values or
religious or political beliefs
hmm
okay well we're getting some feedback
from the man so anyways this is a rough
rough note
rough notes that we have for today
I kind of want to make the perfect wife
resume
if any of you guys have any input you
know skills that you would like your
your significant other to have and this
can be delusional we can make it just
like the 666 is a bit delusional make it
delusional fellas let's make a
delusional
can she kill a chicken
you want your girl to kill a chicken
anyways
um
well well ladies I have to go I have a
meeting coming up
um let me know what you all think in the
comments
we're gonna we're gonna keep this going
we're gonna keep
keep this going but like the video on
your way out
subscribe to the channel alright ring
that notification Bell how do I